[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome once again to I'd like
to know our question and answer program
where we get the privilege and pleasure
of answering your questions from the
word of God I am again in the presence
of two men of God two students of the
word and we like to study the word of
God together we like to answer your
questions together to my left is Pastor
Stephen Bohr our president and founder
to my right is Pastor David Salazar who
is in charge of the general manager of
uh some TV Latino and doing a very very
fine job my name is CA Murray and again
I say it is our privilege and our
pleasure to answer your questions on
this program I'd like to know we want to
say up front if you'd like to get in on
the fun if you'd like to be part of this
program we invite you to do so we
encourage you to do so by writing to us
at TV at some
s-u-m-tv.org that is TV at sumtv.org
and we will try to answer your questions
as best we can from the word of God is a
good thing to study the word of God it
makes you strong in the Lord it gives
you Direction it lets you know where you
are in the Stream of time as we are just
on the borders of the return of our Lord
and Savior Jesus Christ we ought to be a
people of the book students of the word
and that's what we attempt to do and we
make you that promise that we will
always do that as the Lord gives us
strength and ability Pastor Salazar if
you would ask God's blessing on our
sitting today we will launch out into
our questions for this particular
program absolutely let's pray
Heavenly Father we thank you Lord for
allowing us to come together to study
your word and to be able to share with
those that are watching those that are
sending their questions some of the
answers that we can find in your word we
pray that it will lead us into all truth
that as we open our mouths may not be
our words that come through but really
your word and your inspiration allow us
to give answers that will reach the
hearts we pray these in Jesus holy name
amen amen amen amen amen Pastor born I'm
going to ask you to wrestle with this
first one it's in in several sections so
you've got to read it's going to take a
little time just to get through it
um unless you can condense it but let's
take a look at this first question which
comes to us from adeniram
kunya
well
um brother this must be from some
Portuguese speaking country because
nakuna gives him away I know
um this comes from Dayton Ohio it's
amazing as I look at the questions the
many different places that the questions
come from yes from all over the world
that's great because people are watching
us all over the world
um this is uh the question
it says Don from Dayton Ohio thank you
for your faithful Ministry and efforts
to answer challenging Bible questions
then he puts prologue
um an episode
uh Apocrypha reliable I'd like to know
both Dr Murray and Pastor Salazar stated
that God never directly called Jerusalem
or his people for that matter harlots
prostitutes and that was a term almost
exclusively reserved for the papacy from
the Dark Ages until the end time however
this argument is misleading and ignores
the following texts and then he gives
Jerusalem being called to harlot the
Israelites of the Old Testament be
called harlots can you please clear
clarify why Jerusalem and God's people
cannot be harlots once they apostatize
as the religious leaders had during
Jesus ministry and why is it only a term
reserved for the papacy thank you with
regards I have a suspicion although I
obviously wasn't here for that I'd like
to know session because it addresses Dr
Murray and Pastor Salazar I have a
suspicion that what you guys I said is
that the Harlot of Revelation chapter 17
applies to the papacy
but I don't think that it that you meant
that the word Harlot cannot be applied
to Israel and Jerusalem because there
are many texts that say that uh
Jerusalem became a harlot and Israel
became a harlot I think for example many
times in Ezekiel chapter 16 and Ezekiel
chapter 23 Israel is called a harlot but
I think that maybe you were addressing
just Revelation chapter 17 the Harlot
that sits on many Waters which applies
to the Roman Catholic papacy perhaps
Pastor you know and I'm glad that
actually somebody can fact checked us I
mean it's always important and I think
it's a good thing you know because we
can make mistakes obviously that's part
of being a human but probably as you
mentioned we were either you know train
of thought thinking just prophetically
speaking to Direction 17 or in regards
to the heart of that is or you know that
is mentioned well really to the
heartless mentioned as by by
John as regular as the woman that sits
in many water so yeah 2017 I think that
maybe no trainer thought was in that
regard but if we had made a mistake you
know it's good to be checked again so
I'm okay with that too you know yeah I
wanted to know I find it kind of
difficult yeah uh to believe that you
said that uh the word Harlot applies
exclusively to the papacy and it doesn't
apply to Israel and Jerusalem because I
know that you know the Bible and you
would never have said that uh overtly so
my guess is that you were referring to
the Harlem Revelation 17. so anyway but
you know that is important I think it's
important that you know he he feels that
we can accept if you know that we are in
our train of thought we were thinking I
believe what Pastor Mari we were just
thinking about that yeah I I appreciate
the spirit of the question because he
wasn't dogmatic he wasn't right you know
shaking his finger uh it comes from a
nice place yeah um Revelation 17 talks
about the mother of harlots you know uh
we mentioned this a bit ago one of
Israel's consistent problems was going
after other gods drinking from other
cisterns as it were uh which is harlot
harlotry right uh but there is a
difference interestingly enough you know
if you if you get caught with a couple
ounces of cocaine you get one sentence
because that's for personal use if you
get caught with a large amount of
cocaine you get caught you get a tougher
sentence because you're trafficking you
know Israel was always wandering away
small amounts of cocaine yeah whereas
the the Harlot of uh Revelation 17 is
trafficking exactly she's exporting
cocaine to all to to the whole world so
they're not in the same place but one of
Israel's consistent problems was
wandering after other gods you know
wandering after God we see that
throughout the old I mean it's and it's
Peter prophecy or on the Bible of course
speaks of Israel as you know going in
whoredom or or use
acting in adultery that is different
than saying the Harlot
you know and and that's important or
what I mean by that the mother of
Heartless as Revelation 17 mentions so I
think that's important that you know we
make that clear as you were mentioning
the distinction between one or the other
um and yet God has shown that Israel did
commit adultery going After idols going
you know breaking the Sabbath and doing
many things and eventually they actually
were rejected as they were not that pure
holy particular people that God wanted
them to be yeah so so thank you so much
adeniram uh uh you are correct and we
thank you for your and I'm really glad
that everybody that's watching
is making sure that what we say is in
harmony with the Bible exactly that's
what I'm saying
like the Apostle Paul said of the
bereans you know they checked me out yes
that's good you know if we do say
something that is not in harmony with
scripture uh you know we're not
omniscient
um even on this program there might be
cases where we say something that
somebody who has watched the program
says hey you know there's this
perspective we might have to say well
you know
um thank you for giving us the
information we've grown in our
understanding yes exactly so yeah and we
praise the Lord for that that's great
that is great now this next question
comes from Isaac Quran this is a young
man who we actually interviewed a few
weeks ago at uh ASI young man oh he's
sub 20 maybe in 19 just turning 20. he's
a Bible worker and uh wants to be a
pastor he's starting to be a pastor uh
you can see the the light in his eyes
he's in love with the Lord he also
mentioned Pastor that one of the things
that kept him during his teenage years
you know you have those Wilderness years
where you're prone to kind of wander
right he said one of the things that
kept him was binge watching some TV
with binge watch you watch you over and
over and again again and program you
watch one program several times until he
had it almost memorized it's a nice
young man it really does uh uh great to
interview him that interview will be
coming up on um the Overcomers in the
future the question is quite long uh do
you want to try to summarize this for us
I think maybe you know there's several
there's several points here
uh maybe I can deal with one of them
which I think will uh explain the others
um so let me just read the first part
hello this is Isaac from Missouri
first I want to thank you guys for
putting on this program and for the
ministry of Secrets unsealed I watch
your programs and anchor class as often
Lord willing I'll be able to come
someday and have been very blessed by
them my question is with regards to
Daniel 7 22.
and great controversy page 660 paragraph
four
I'm reading through the great
controversy in the evenings and couldn't
find a satisfactory answer to this
question then he quotes the verse Daniel
7 22 until the Ancient of Days came and
judgment was given
the margin says Made in favor of was
given to the Saints of the most high and
the time came came that the Saints
possessed the kingdom
it was my understanding that this refers
to the father entering the most holy
place in 1844 and that the margin was
the better translation
because judgment is given in favor of
the Saints however Ellen White appears
to use this verse in a totally different
way in the great controversy page 660
paragraph four in the way that she uses
it it makes it appear that the coming of
the ancient some days is the second
coming
so how do we explain uh Daniel 7 and
verse 22 is it a judgment in favor of
the Saints or is a judgment given for
the Saints to judge that's a big
question well in context I think the
best explanation is uh that that
judgment is given in favor of the Saints
of the most high because the context
indicates that the little horn is mowing
down the Saints of the most high there's
no justice for them on Earth Revelation
says that crying out for justice until
when do you not judge and avenge our
blood which is said on the Earth
and so
um in Daniel chapter 7 it's saying that
uh God's people are persecuted by the
little horn but the time is coming when
judgment was given will be given in
favor of the Saints of the most high
because the little horn judged unjustly
yes I think that that fits the context
better so how do we deal with the issue
that Ellen White seems to apply uh this
verse to the second coming well the
question is when is a judgment going to
be given in favor of the most high
well let's go to Daniel 7 22 and read
the entire verse it says there
uh until the Ancient of Days came that's
1844.
the Judgment uh until uh the Ancient of
Days came and judgment was made in favor
of the Saints of the most high
and now comes that reference to the
second coming
and
the time came for the Saints to possess
the kingdom that's the second coming so
so the first part of the verse is
dealing with the Judgment that begins in
1844 and the purpose is to exonerate the
Saints of the most high the Believers
True Believers in Jesus and the second
half of the verse says that after
they're judged then uh Jesus comes and
they possess the kingdom now we need to
understand that
um in the Bible the system of
jurisprudence is the same as the system
of jurisprudence in the United States of
America there's three stages the first
stage is the investigation right the
second stage is the sentence based on
the investigation and the third stage is
the actual execution of the sentence
either positive or negative of course so
so we have this in Daniel 7 the Ancient
of Days Jesus comes to the Ancient of
Days for the Judgment that's the
investigative stage a sentence is
pronounced in favor of the Saints the
most high in that judgment and then the
time comes for them to possess the
kingdom which is the execution of the
sentence so there's no contradiction
between Ellen White and Daniel chapter 7
when you take a look at the entire verse
and I also might mention that Ellen
White does the same thing with
Revelation chapter 20 14 15. in context
uh Revelation 20 verses 14 and 15 maybe
we can have somebody read that
Revelation 20 verses 14 and verse 15.
who wants to read that
it says
did I say 2014 and 15 yes
um let's see actually uh verse 12.
12 okay 12.
and I saw the death small and great
stand before God and the books were
opened and another book was opened which
is The Book of Life and the death were
judged out of those things which were
written in the books according to their
works now Ellen White uses this verse to
refer to the pre-advent investigative
judgment and she also uses it for the
millennial judgment yes no why does why
does she do that she does it because the
process is the same exactly she's not
saying that though that that verse
applies to two stages technically
speaking what she's saying is that the
process of the Dead standing before God
that's their their dead but their cases
are being examined you know they're
being examined right and then after the
examination you have a sentence which is
eternal death and then in verses 14 and
15 you have the execution of the
sentence where they're cast into the
Lake of Fire
so Ellen White sometimes uses verses to
express a principle other times she
usually uses them strictly within the
temporal context in which they appear in
the text amen Christ says in Revelation
I'm coming and my reward is with me with
me technically
when Christ comes if you follow the the
logic of first Thessalonians 4
.
um all cases are decided when Christ
comes back those who are going to be in
are in those who are going to be out are
out
he mentioned great controversy 660 verse
4 a paragraph four so I'm just going to
run through a bit of that so we we get
the context during the Thousand Years
between the first and second
Resurrection the Judgment of the wicked
takes place now technically that is just
a ratification that what God did he did
well and he was he was correct so we get
to see by looking at his works that he
did everything as it should have been
done the Apostle Paul points to this
judgment as an event that follows the
second Advent judge nothing before its
time until the Lord come who both will
bring light to bring to light the hidden
things of darkness and will make
manifest the councils of the hearts one
of the things we are told axiomatically
is that when we get to heaven one of the
things we will be surprised we didn't
think certain people would be there they
are there some people who we are sure
would be there they are not there so one
of the things that we will decide and
understand for ourselves do during this
time is that God doeth all things well
everybody had a fair chance everybody
got a fair shot so we will look over the
records and certify that God did
correctly that which should have been
done you know it's also interesting that
in Revelation chapter 20 like I
mentioned verse 12 it says that dead are
standing before God dead people can't
stand before God
it's their record that stands before God
because it says books are open the dead
stand before God through their books
but then verse 13 speaks about the
resurrection of the wicked and then they
will see their records because verse 13
says the sea gave up the Dead who were
in it
and death in Hades delivered up the Dead
who were in them
that's the resurrection right when it
says here the sea gave up the dead and
death in Hades delivered up the dead
it's talking about the resurrection
after the Millennium and then it says
and they were judged each one according
to his works so the wicked during the
Millennium do not see
the the investigation of their case
of course but F but the sentence is
pronounced then after the millennium
they will see the record of their lives
and then they will confess that their
sentence is just and then God will
execute the sentence you know this is
unique to The Seventh-Day Adventist
Church this concept of judgment most
people think that the judgment is when
Jesus comes you know when Jesus comes
he's going to take the righteous to
Heaven he's going to he's going to put
the wicked in the fire or or have them
continue in the fire because they
believe that they're cast there at death
but but God's system of jurisprudence is
the same as as in the United States of
America yes you know the judge doesn't
say
uh you know you're right
um let him go you know you're wrong
life in prison no no no no there's it's
first of all an investigation of the
case the evidence
then based on the evidence there's a
verdict
and then after the verdict comes a time
when the sentence is executed
God is not less just
then the jurisprudence that is applied
here we have copied God's method of
judgment absolutely now the Judgment
Pastor you know and you're mentioning
this already the Judgment that is
started in 1844 the investigative
judgment is for God's people those are
professed right the name of Jesus and I
think that's something that sometimes
people get a little confused they
somewhat think that that judgment
includes everybody you know it's like
for every single human being Wicked and
not Wicked but really the judgments is
for God's people or those that profess
the name of Jesus and uh or had the
light and the Judgment for the righteous
is of course finished or executed
favorably when Christ comes and takes us
and redeems us but the Judgment itself
continues you know and this is kind of
another thing that I believe this is why
the Bible connects them you know because
the Judgment continues through the
thousands of years there's a judgment
that takes place so the Judgment doesn't
necessarily stop it's it's for the
righteous ends in favor but then the the
Judgment for the whole human race
continues for a thousand years and then
there's execution for them so you know
the the sentencing and execution for
them so in a sense as you would
mentioned in Daniel 7 22 when he speaks
of that it kind of connects the you know
the the righteous Judgment of the
righteous the Judgment that is in given
to the righteous to for them to judge
and uh and then the Judgment for the the
wicked which will be given by the by the
by the righteous do so I suppose that's
why the verse can be in some ways
applied to both parts as you mentioned
early on you know um the contrast
between the concept of Judgment of the
Adventist Church and the Christian World
in general
is that for the Christian World in
general
the judgment is an event
for us it is a process
because because you know even the Creed
is wrong it says that he shall come to
judge the living and the dead no he's
not coming to judge the living and the
dead he did he he separated the
righteous before the second coming right
which which by default the wicked have
already been judged really exactly
except the millennial judgment will
reveal why they were they were lost
um the the Adventist concept of judgment
is biblical
but if you believe in once saved always
saved yeah there's no rationale for the
Judgment because once you're saved you
can never be lost so why would there not
be necessary a judgment and that is why
people reject anything post you know the
cross right you know because they say
what's the point of intercession there's
no need for a century and all those
things and and this is the danger of
putting your mind or your uh idea into
the concept that you want safe always
save because you will reject a lot big
portion of the scriptures that tells us
what's happening or why Christ what
Christ is doing today in heaven it also
has to do with the state of the dead
right because if you believe that when a
person dies very much then they will
Wicked they go to hell
and they're still living in hell
and that the righteous go to heaven
then the Judgment took place when you
died precisely see for for the Christian
world
a person the Judgment takes place when
you die
because when you die you either go to
hell or you go to heaven but for the
Adventist Church when you die you know
nothing and then your case is examined
in the Heavenly court and it's
determined whether you're saved or lost
and then the verdict is pronounced and
then comes the time to inherit the
Kingdom thoroughly biblical thoroughly
thoroughly but people don't want the
idea that we have to appear before the
Judgment seat of Christ the Bible says
we must all appear before the Judgment
seat of Christ and Paul is speaking to
the Corinthian Church right we must all
appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ amen you know when you start out
on the wrong foot you can never get
right when you when you give man an
immortal Soul at creation then you've
got to put that Soul someplace when he
dies you you and you've got a great
making of theology either it's got to be
in heaven or it's got to be in Hell
neither one is is correct God subjects
himself to the what and the why for us
we know what is going to happen at the
second coming during the thousand years
we get to understand why and you know
how it happened so and God does that for
us because he knows the truth he knows
that those are that are in heaven should
be there and those that are not in
heaven shouldn't be there but we may
need to know right and the world the
universe needs to know so God subjects
himself to that the what and the why
um let's see I'm looking at my time
we've got something real quick at the
close of the thousand years the second
Resurrection will take place then the
wicked will be raised from the dead and
appear before God for the execution of
the Judgment written as you had said yes
there there it is thus the Revelator
after describing the resurrection of the
righteous says the rest of the Dead live
not again until the thousand years were
finished that of course is revelation 20
verse 5. so it it's very logical it's
very sequential and it is it is an
Adventist gift to Systematic Theology
because it's so logical more than that
it's the word of God and the Judgment
takes place before the Angels because
Bible says I will confess their names
before the angels of heaven yes so the
purpose of the pre-advent investigative
judgment is to convince the Heavenly
beings who are not omniscient that God
has a right to take this group of people
to Heaven that's right that's why God
has to show who has a right to be taken
to heaven to the Heavenly beings before
it happens during the Millennium God
will convince God's people who are there
why certain people aren't there and
after the Millennium God will convince
Satan is angels and the wicked that he
acted properly and correctly correctly I
can admire a god
who really takes into consideration
how everyone looks at him in other words
God the purpose of the judgment is to
vaccinate the universe against the
possibility of another Rebellion he
subjects himself to the what and the why
for us and for the universe this is a
very good question and uh uh one that we
need to we need to revisit and talk
periodically about the second coming and
the state of the Dead End Amen uh what's
going to happen with God's people and
what is going to happen with those who
are lost one of the things it does it
makes you certain I don't want to be in
that second group
[Laughter]
in the first group the group that uh
when Christ comes hails him as Lord and
you another good program gentlemen
praise lord well done and we praise the
Lord for that again we want to encourage
you please
send in your questions because we love
to answer and as you can see we have a
good time doing so it is it is fun to
study the word of God sometimes we need
to put these computers and these
televisions and radios and these these
things that occupy so much of our time
away and spend time in the word it will
benefit you again our time of Swift and
Eternity allow me and closing to wish
you Grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ we'll see you again
soon bye bye and God bless
thank you
[Music]
foreign